Hi everyone, my name is Sai Vennam
and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
Today let's talk about Red Hat OpenShift on IBM Cloud.
First, we'll introduce OpenShift.
OpenShift is an open source application platform
based on Kubernetes and container technology.
It focuses on making the Kubernetes experience easier
for developers, as well as operations teams.
Red Hat OpenShift on IBM Cloud allows you
to focus on managing and developing your application.
Let us take care of the heavy lifting with the infrastructure,
allowing you to create a highly available
and managed OpenShift cluster with the click of a button.
Together, OpenShift and IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service is a perfect match,
providing you with an industry-leading developer experience.
For one, you will get automated provisioning,
updates and patching,
as well as 24/7 global support.
Currently we manage over 14,000 production clusters
in IBM Cloud Kubernetes Service.
In addition, you can resiliency and security across the board.
Take advantage of highly available masters
to administer your clusters
and use options for dedicated computing resources and bare metal.
With multizone regions,
you get stability across data centers
- further enhancing your  HA story.
On the security front, you get compliance out-of-the-box
with things like HIPAA and GDPR.
Finally, you get push-button integrations
with the entire suite of IBM and Red Hat middleware.
Build beyond those basics,
and start taking advantage of high value services,
like AI and Hyperledger capabilities.
With Red Hat and IBM together,
we're building out a unified open hybrid cloud platform.
Whether you're running on-premises, or in the cloud,
taking advantage of Kubernetes, OpenShift,
serverless, or CF technology,
IBM Cloud is unifying these choices
and bringing them under one management platform
powered by open container technologies.
With the unified Red Hat and IBM Cloud platform,
start planning your open hybrid cloud strategy today.